hey everybody it's Charlie this is going
to be my Logan Easter egg just careful
for spoilers if you haven't seen the
movie yet there are a whole bunch there
were a whole bunch of literal comic book
Easter eggs because of the comic books
that Laura was carrying with her in the
movie and then it got really meta with
the Deadpool teaser so I'm just going to
try to include everything I possibly can
there were way more than 20 but I'm
doing this as a top 20 so if I find some
extras I'm making this video then I'll
just add them to the end and the Logan
giveaway is still going on right now all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
it for IMAX gift certificates so here we
go top 20 the Deadpool teaser we all saw
I've worked hard in this lifestyle you
want to end up kidding no not on my
watch there were two different versions
the theatrical version didn't have
Stanley in it they swapped some of the
songs out there was the angel of the
morning from the first Deadpool song the
online version had st. Elmo's fire
within the teaser itself there were a
bunch of Easter eggs I've already done a
separate video for that like a Deadpool
2 trailer video I'll link that at the
end of this there was a title
Logan obviously adapted from old man
Logan the comic book a lot of those also
the origin story of x-23 in the comics
her first big run so they changed a
whole bunch of things but the aspect of
old man Logan they adapted was the big
twist where most of the mutants if not
all the mutants are dead only the change
was is that Professor X accidentally
killed them when he had a seizure at
least the main x-men they called it the
Westchester incident 400 other regular
people were killed the rest of the
mutants were rounded up systematically
by Xander Rice's Weapon X program so you
all remember that really cool Johnny
Cash Hurt cover of the Nine Inch Nails
song back when Craig Kyle and
Christopher Yost were writing the
original x-23 story they had to pitch
they included part of the hurt lyrics
because they felt that they had special
meaning to the character to the
Wolverine character so then that later
became part of the trailer
so this is all the way back to the
original creation of x-23 in the comics
huge deep cut
but speaking of songs when he wakes up
in the doctor's chair later in the movie
there's a song playing on the radio it's
the same song playing when he woke up in
the 70s during Days of Future past also
from that room he has a samurai sword
that's left over from his time in Japan
sort of an easter egg for Wolverine in
Japan but in the second Wolverine movie
there's a samurai sword that he also
gets that appears inside his home where
they're hiding out with Professor X
where they're trying to take care of him
so it's sort of an easter egg for The
Wolverine movie but you could also look
at it as a Days of Future past Easter
egg from his apartment in that movie but
speaking of Days of Future past I know
that movie changed a lot of the
continuity and effectively erased x3 and
Wolverine Origins from the timeline but
one of the big Easter eggs from
Wolverine Origins was the adamantium
bullets that was a big plot point in
that movie the one thing that could kill
him in his escape from that facility he
walks away with an adamantium bullet but
also kills van der Rice's father the
person that put the adamantium in his
body your father put this poison in me
in his van der rice kind of jokes about
the ideas that Wolverine probably killed
him after that happen in the thing is to
take it a step further so there's a
whole bunch of Van der Rice Weapon X
Wolverine Origins Easter eggs is the
thing that was suppressing his healing
factor was the adamantium itself the
poison that your father put in me so the
thing that made him unbreakable was
literally killing him that was a bit of
a metaphor in the movie the thing that
turned him into a weapon was also slowly
killing him from the inside out now the
bonus for this is that x-23 her entire
skeleton is an adamantium it's just the
claws that are adamantium so she could
grow like a normal person in presumably
won't get poisoned by it eventually
later in life so another big Weapon X
Easter Egg is Donald Pierce in the
comics he's the leader of the reverse
they end up becoming this cyborg group
that works with Yuriko who becomes Lady
Deathstrike Wolverines
old love interest from Wolverine in
Japan so she was a relatively minor
character during the Wolverine spin-off
movie and they didn't do a lot of that
storyline they didn't do Lady
Deathstrike the Lady Deathstrike of the
x-men movies was a
for a character that appeared during x2
x-men United the company that Xander
rice was working for alkali transgender
the companies that he owned is actually
an offshoot of the Essex corporation but
the alkali name is an Easter Egg for
alkali Lake which is where the original
Weapon X program was located so Weapon X
mr. sinister Easter Egg
[Music]
the funerals that he goes to is
Greenwood Cemetery it's from the Marvel
Universe a couple smaller Marvel
characters had been buried there they
referenced a whole bunch of stuff from
the first x-men movie they're waiting
for you at the Statue of Liberty the
Statue of Liberty was a long time ago
Charles now obviously in the movie it's
the Statue of Liberty motel but the
Statue of Liberty was the big climax
action scene of the first x-men film
probably one of the best uses the film
within film the movie that they're
watching is Shane is basically the same
story as the Logan movie this old
gunslinger wants to settle down start a
family but this evil person comes in and
tries to push them out so he has to pick
up his guns again so to speak he has to
pop his claws like Wolverine does so
it's basically the plot of that movie so
the x24 is sort of an Easter Egg for
Daken just suck the most hardcore
version of Wolverine you could imagine
x-23 is super hardcore but the way the
movie uses him isn't somebody from the
comics but there was no x24 clone of
Wolverine from the comics he has this
unnamed AK and who picks up the mantle
but he's not exactly like the clone so
that's a bit of an easter egg for daca
just hardcore version of Wolverine but
talking about comic book Easter eggs so
the actual comics that x-23 is carrying
around or Easter Egg for Chris Claremont
stories but they had to change the cover
art because of licensing issues so Joe
Quezada and another artist wrote these
news stories one of them was just a
funny story about Kitty Pryde family
coming to visit her at the x-mansion and
not knowing that she was a mutant the
other story was about them visiting the
Savage Land Sauron is on the cover so a
lot of you were asking about Eden it's
not an actual place from the Marvel
comics but they could have been
referring to the Savage Land just like a
remote place where they could go live
out their lives but the Savage Land in
the comics is actually a pretty bad
place to go but speaking of which when
they were trying to cross the border
there was a character named Richter so
he is from the x-force comic so there
was a big x-force Easter Egg in the
movie now all of the new mutants in the
movie had DNA taken from older x-men
characters so if you remember the mutant
that had lightning powers his DNA was
taken from Christopher Bradley Dominic
Monaghan character so even though
technically that movie was erased by
Days of Future
ass they still had a big easter egg for
him he still exists in the universe
somewhere I didn't get a great look at
all the names of the DNA that they took
but there was somebody with eyes powers
which might have been an easter egg for
Ice Man DNA there was somebody with fire
powers which might have been a pyro
easter egg so you have to imagine that
they kept the DNA from all the major
x-men characters the most powerful
mutants and we're trying to grow newer
versions of them in these younger
children the last real big easter egg we
got to talk about the yellow costume
obviously there wasn't any literal
yellow comic book costume but he was
wearing it inside the comic book and oh
I almost forgot this should actually be
number one is the Stan Lee cameo so Stan
Lee claims that his cameo was cut from a
Logan he had a cameo somewhere in there
that hasn't been revealed yet because he
appeared in the Deadpool trailer and
thank Ryan Reynolds from saving him from
obscurity it was a total joke because
obviously everybody knows who Stan Lee
is but apparently he shot a scene for
Logan that was cut out of the movie so
you guys can speculate about what that
might have been he might have been one
of the people in the background playing
slots whenever they were wheeling
Professor X through the floor of that
casino well let me know if you guys
spotted any more Easter eggs from Logan
I'll be doing a couple more Logan
Deadpool videos this week so I'll try to
get those out as fast as possible I have
some flash coming up and they dumped a
whole bunch of Wonder Woman news there's
going to be a new Wonder Woman trailer
maybe Tuesday morning so whenever that
post I will totally do a video for it
congratulations to last week's Logan
giveaway winner hit man Quinn you win
IMAX gift certificates please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details there
was a new round that started in this
video I'll announce the winner the next
time I post a Logan Deadpool video what
you wait for that you can click here for
that Deadpool trailer and you can click
here for my Logan review video thank you
so much for watching let's high-five
I'll see you guys in the next video